she wrote it she sent it having an
unsent is bad but being on the receiving
end of an unsent is even worse I went on
a date with this lovely lady let's call
her Pam it wasn't terribly great I was
just kind of hoping that maybe I just
wouldn't hear from her two days ago bye
I get a text message from Pam hey I had
a great time what are you doing tonight
it was a Saturday by the way and even if
I had a great time I don't know if I was
ready to give up my Saturday at this
point I don't really know what to do I
don't want to be a dick and then Pam
sends a text message and it's really
long nothing this long is ever good in a
text message I mean I feel like we can I
quickly realize it's not addressed to me
it's addressed to a friend of Pam's so
I've asked him what he's doing tonight
he's busy oh by the way you just like
another girls picture on Instagram which
I thought was a bit of a red flag now I
don't know what to do but before I even
get a chance to decide I get another
text from Pam oMG I can't believe I sent
it to you and I'm guessing you don't
want to go out with me anymore I did it
so I panicked and feel really bad and
reply oh no big deal I'll totally go out
with you again
pro tip sometimes ghosting is the nicest
thing you can do
you